and she said you know my son passed away
15 years ago and i said i'm so sorry she
says oh that's okay
you came to visit me two years ago
[Music]
i said really
she said oh yes
what would you do if you were confronted
by an angel find out on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome back to
led live everyone we are excited to have
another episode with producer and
director chris lange
by this time you would have the
opportunity to see his new docu-drama
called charmed by darkness so we're here
to talk a little bit about that a little
bit more about
what happens behind the scenes his
encounter with
an angel yeah and some things that
happened in roger's life so we're gonna
just continue that conversation this
week we're excited to have you with us
and we're gonna turn it over to chris
chris
tell us a little bit about how you got
involved in this work
well it's it's uh it's been an
incredible journey guys i wasn't trained
in filmmaking uh my background is in
finance and i actually got an mba
and it was in the business world for a
number of years no that was nba not nba
right
no
these chairs are very uh misleading
misleading yeah some of us are sure
you're not like six five or anything
okay no i'm not i'm not the hired of my
friend brad it's my summer's fault some
of the rest of you brad's literally
sitting on the floor
[Laughter]
so mba and what'd you do with that so
yeah so i worked in a large
healthcare company
for a number of years and then i left
and started a small business and i'm
going to tell a story in a few minutes
about how for those of you out there
working in the field whatever industry
and maybe you're starting a career maybe
you're done with college or maybe you're
still in college trying to figure out
what you want to do
i'm a witness
to tell you today that god cares about
god amen whatever you were born to do if
you seek him he'll let you know amen and
so that's really what this testimony is
about today i'm calling it back to
ground zero
because there's been times in my life
when the devil tries to whisper in my
mind and tell me you don't really
believe that stuff do you
no i'm sure that never happens to you
yeah
so um i'm so thankful that that
god wants us
to
see evidence and have an intelligent
faith there's so many people that attack
christianity today and they say
your faith is just a crutch that you
lean on there's no substance to it
and yet they're happy to watch
superheroes movies or movies about
ghosts and fallen and demons and they
have no idea what they're dealing with
right it's just entertainment to them
but we happen to believe that there's a
great god that's above all things who
actually knows your name amen and that's
that's why i believe god called me here
today on little light studios to share
uh this great god and to actually
encourage all of you including you guys
here with me today in the studio amen
was it hard to make a career change
it wasn't easy i like to tell people it
was like jumping off the cliff
in that sense it took faith that didn't
have a lot of
substance but i i'm going to tell you
another uh one of these stories that i'm
going to tell you that god
did a miracle in my life while i was in
the business world to help me understand
you can trust me
i say that question with with a little
bit of you know laughing inside myself
because everybody sitting at this table
has essentially had a career change
that's true
so we all know what you're going through
[Laughter]
well for me it's been a 10 plus year
journey i mean this started back in the
double o's
uh
and
and so i want to talk more about that
but but before we get into that personal
sort of sharing with the with the
audience i want to touch on a question
that i'm sure came up last week in last
week's episode
about roger morneau and this amazing
film that i had the privilege to work
with his family to produce over the last
seven years
well when i was researching and this
book is actually a companion to the film
this is roger's autobiography the
complete manuscript
when i was researching this the question
was coming up in my mind and people were
asking
why was it that a 21 year old
young man in in montreal canada was
being sought out by the spirits to join
a luciferian society i had that same
question
what made him unique among other 21 year
olds
and so i
i prayed about it and during my research
and i talked to his family
and i believe i have a reasonable answer
roger passed away in 1998.
so we can't talk to the man himself yeah
but but from the fruits of his life and
from the evidence from people who knew
him um
it goes like this as a young lad roger
could not reconcile
the teachings of his church with those
of the bible
interesting he was a very sincere young
boy nine years old when he started
asking his parents questions about the
meaning of life in the bible
and the answers he was getting were not
reconciling for his young mind
and roger came to believe that god was a
tyrant
the god of this book
that whatever he knew about the god of
this book he he came to believe that
that god was a tyrant
his mother died when he was 12. and he
was told by his uncle who was a catholic
priest
that his mother had
bypassed purgatory and gone straight
into heaven because his father was
wealthy and was able to pay for
gregorian masses so that she didn't have
to suffer there wow on the other hand
this 12 year old boy was told that
little old annie who was their maid in
their home when he was a boy taking care
of the cooking and the cleaning
godly woman who passed away very poor
without any family
no one could do gregorian masses for old
annie
and so the priest told young roger that
that godly woman was suffering in
purgatory
in the flames to be purified before she
could be accepted into heaven because of
wow
it was all the twelve-year-old boy could
see right through it yeah and that
to him was unreckless irreconcilable
yeah if if a god in heaven
would do that to a woman like that yeah
he said i don't want anything to do with
it but what's crazy is okay you have the
god in heaven who can create worlds by
just speaking it into existence he can
create whatever he wants if he needs
money he can speak it into existence
okay yeah like that just makes no
logical sense whatsoever you have to you
have to say this has got to be some
man's devise or
you know like somebody's
corrupt here in this chain and and
secondarily to that where where does he
get that where does that sense of
justice come from like how does he know
that that idea is wrong he just knows
and how does any kid know
that's wrong
you know that comes from somewhere i
think god has put this on our hearts the
bible says that god has given a measure
of faith to every man
everyone born into the world is given a
conscience
and what do you do with it is the
question and that young roger
was a was a very sincere young mind um
and brilliant young boy
and so he went into world war ii uh he
was a teenage late teenager
and served his country and we showed the
evidence in the film nobody many people
didn't believe his story
and we found the proof that he actually
was telling the truth so you'll see the
documents if you haven't seen the movie
go look at it on youtube it's free
charmed by darkness um
and so he he he comes out of the war
he's 21 years old after he served his
country
and he
meets a war buddy who invites him to go
to seances and then there's a a person
who meets him there at the seances who's
actually connected to a luciferian
secret society and this man ultimately
tells roger that a spirit told him
to go
find roger spoke of roger by name
to go and select him and invite him to
come to the meetings
why would a spirit do that and i i i'm
getting to the point of all of this and
that is
roger was young
he was smart
and most importantly he hated the god of
this book
at that time
but what i love about this story is that
in this coming-of-age story of a 21 year
old young man who by the way ultimately
meets a 19 year old at his factory cyril
gross and his wife who was 19 at the
time
this is a coming-of-age story for our
very viewers today
it's it's timeless and here's the point
god knew that this young 21 year old
mind was deceived
i love the god that i serve because
roger didn't know the truth about this
god
that we serve
and so god didn't allow young roger to
be destroyed in that secret society
right
instead
because roger was sincere searching for
something real
because his parents told him don't don't
mess around with wickedness because
someday you're going to pay the price
and and one night he was laying in bed
at 2 00 a.m he couldn't sleep and he
cries out and he doesn't even know he's
praying if there's a god in heaven who
cares for me
help me yes
it was a short prayer
and three days later he met cyril in the
factory wow why did he cry out why
couldn't he sleep because the secret
society had been giving him miracles
and the great master who they referred
to as lucifer
was pressuring him to get initiated and
he was very hesitant there was something
not right about it
we remember we just talked about a
measure of faith given to every man
what are you going to do with that
conscience
roger roger was hesitant
and his friend was ready to dive right
in yeah but roger was holding back
and the holy spirit of god was holding
him back amen isn't that something
that's awesome wow so
so the link to today's episode is is
that
god doesn't ask you and me to believe
without evidence right yeah absolutely
what's amazing to me is how
no matter how you hear about this secret
society or you look at like hollywood's
messages or whatever it's always aimed
at misconstruing the character of god
that's right i mean you see it over and
over and over again that's the number
one thing that the devil just loves to
do is to just be like oh yeah you know
that god yeah he's this crazy mean guy
and you know he's just holding back from
you and i mean he said the same lie that
you've seen from the garden of eden from
you know the matrix or from whatever
they're literally repackaging this thing
and you see this consistent thread
through anyone that's on the enemy's
side and um if they only have the proper
picture of the truth
that's why i believe it's so important
what you're doing
and you're you know you're not even a
filmmaker this is what i love about this
story you're a guy that just like all of
a sudden got the got the heart and just
was like okay god give me the people
give me the tools i'm gonna go out and
make this film i don't even know how to
do this but i'm going to do this anyway
here's the thing that's really cool
about god
is he knew that i loved cameras and he
knew that i loved great stories and he
knew that i loved this that's awesome
it was a perfect storm
and it's not been easy as you all well
know
but i wouldn't trade it for anything you
know what else is fascinating is here
roger is rejecting this picture of god
that he's had from a young age
and then when he's presented with
you know
a different reality like here's here's
the occult world they're ready to offer
you this this this and this
it's
it's as real as anything else that he's
known
it's it's it's gonna provide some
tangibility
and and yet
he doesn't
take it it's like it's like i know this
picture of christianity that i was given
i reject that i don't want that i don't
want that god and yet when he's
presented with the other side he holds
out
and it's like it's amazing that he holds
out because it's like you know here's
everything you probably ever want on a
platter
why not just go for it you know i want
to give a shout out to every sincere
person who follows as much of this as
they know
roger's parents were roman catholic
and they lived their faith in the best
way they knew how and they prayed for
young roger and they told him don't mess
around with the evil because someday
you're going to pay the price there was
something about the luciferian society
and the way they bragged about yes
deceiving people in the world and that
just really
what gave him pause but ultimately his
parents
um influence on his young mind kept
coming back to him someday you're gonna
pay the price and so as a 21 year old to
get a long-range view yeah what is the
price i might have to pay
isn't that funny that the devil he puts
the accusation on god he says ah he's
the one that he just wants your money
but then you sit and you look at the
situation like this and it's like no no
he's the one that's that's wanting your
money he's the one that's literally
holding the strength more than your
money yeah he's holding the strings and
and it's like you know he his
accusations literally can be turned
around right on what he's doing though
and the the society actually is what
showed him that this whole thing is real
that what he's actually dealing with i
mean he hated god he understood god the
whole the whole time but if he really
believed at that time he might have a
second opinion try to go read read the
bible again but the society showed him
that
hey what is going on here is legit
perhaps i need to take a second look
into the other side of things before i
make my decision right that's what
happened with the the documentary out of
shadows that was the
real famous hollywood stunt
uh what do you call a stunt devil a guy
or whatever
he got in a bad accident and
a lady that worked in the hospital was
saying that there's all kinds of like
crazy ritualistic pedophilia stuff in
hollywood and he he didn't believe it
but she's like they they come here i'm
the one that sees him firsthand you know
i'm a pelvic doctor and all this stuff
so he was saying i came to christ not
because i went to a church but because i
seen the darkness the reality of the
dark side made me realize there has to
be this other side and that's the whole
thing that happened morneau brings out
in his original book which if you by the
way i'm going to grab this
this being the original the full copy of
what marnell wrote and i read the first
one which was like half of what is in
here and
the half of it in morneau says in the
1700s satan and the rest of the minions
went to make a big meeting and said we
have to go underground we have to be
quiet about this because if we are quiet
about what we're doing with all this um
you know don't go to the 13th floor
don't go to you know don't let a black
cat walk across your path all these
tricks and stuff that we're doing that's
blatant it out is making people believe
there is a spiritual realm and if
there's a spiritual realm in satan's
realm there's a spiritual in god's realm
it's actually not helping us so if they
go underground
and hide make it more like it's fake oh
yeah somebody's just making this out
they can make god disappear too which is
exactly what happened make the devil
look like a little character wearing red
pajamas that's right
possession like really foaming out the
mouth and puking green vom and
everything
so
you see too many movies that's what i'm
saying they're they're
parodying they're making the church look
like a parody you know yeah right no
he's very happy and i make a statement
and charmed by darkness about this very
thing that the more he can make fun of
the biblical narrative the more he can
get away with the red horns and the
pitchfork and uh creating these
caricatures
of the devil
not being a real person it's just a
caricature of halloween
and um but god doesn't ask us to believe
without evidence and the bible says
taste and see
that the lord
is good amen and i want to share some of
the ways that i've tasted and i've seen
that the lord is not only real
but that he is very good amen
so i want to share yesterday we talked a
little bit about
uh beware of angels which is another
film kind of an offshoot of this
conversion of this man roger moore now
who ended up writing six books and he's
well known for his prayer intercessory
prayer ministry
which is the subject of our next film
that i'm working on right now but this
this movie beware of angels came out a
couple of years ago
and i wanted to show the trailer real
quick and then tell you a
behind-the-scenes miracle that happened
to me that you'll be able to appreciate
and i hope the viewers will too all
right
they had prayed to sea
at 10th and angels
[Music]
no one knew that i was a disciple of the
ascended master spirit guide joel cole
i could pierce that veil and see these
spiritual beings that i thought were
dead ancestors who have passed on and
now
have received these bodies
if it was too dark i'm like well i don't
do dark
all those books made me feel good
who do you serve
i said no one he said nah nah everybody
serves somebody now who's it gonna be i
said well myself i guess he said so be
it
there is really no escape because there
is nowhere to escape to
i could see their faces because they
weren't covered
what have i got myself into
[Music]
so this is a collection of stories of
people that have angel encounters
the tie to what we were just talking
about guys about the 1700 meetings with
lucifer and his generals and planning
the future that we're going to burn the
bible we're going to get rid of the
bible without burning it like they did
in the dark ages that was one of the
plans um another plan was to bring
hypnotism into the realm of the sciences
so uh and then uh there was a there was
a third which which dealt with darwin
bringing evolution on the scene which
happened just a few decades after that
meeting
so
this movie actually ties in amazingly to
that part of our conversation because
these are
these are actual people real people
some of whom are pretty well known in
certain christian circles and even in
occult circles mark clemenson is one of
the stories who
was brought up in a freemason home his
grandfather was a high-ranking mason
and he was being groomed
to take that masonic apron
and and then another story is adam
hendren who was having lucid dreams of
aliens that wanted him to take his life
and meet them on the other side it
happened to be a female alien
that was interacting with him in his
dreams very lucid dreams
he was studying all kinds of religions
all kinds of different world views about
finding what's real what's truth what's
what's my purpose of life and this is a
question everyone asks
um
and then a third this young lady who uh
was reading all these books like the
secret and uh
all kinds of quote books uh books on
witchcraft etc
and she got lost in the coldness of the
new age
where god isn't the person god is a
force in the universe
uh like star wars that made this popular
this concept that god is not a person
which is nothing more than eastern
mysticism from buddhism and um and it's
been of course westernized in this new
age concept which embraces christianity
as long as jesus isn't your savior right
by the way they like to quote scripture
too
um
and then of course you have will baron
who was a new age priest in the early
80s and he was seeing angels who were
claiming to be from heaven and
and uh
dua joel cool uh who out of alice bailey
interacted with and channeled all of her
books from the 40s
which is now part of the united nations
which is very sobering stuff
the lord pulled all of these people out
of their deceptions
and the reason it's connected to roger
morneau's book beware of angels is
because these were christians who were
asking to talk with angels and so yes
all of these people were seeing angels
in some form
but they ultimately why are all these
stories in one movie because there's a
thread that goes through every one of
them
every one of them shows the thread that
you will not surely die
the original
every single one of them and i just
praise the lord because
while i was working on this i was going
to bring roger's story into it and we
were going to keep this for the
screenplay this title
um god had other plans we didn't get the
money for this screenplay yet if
somebody's wealthy wants to finance the
screenplay where we reenact his secret
society experience that's
told in the book
god bless you call me um
but in the meantime this docudrama that
uh that premiered on youtube last week
uh
it it it incorporates a lot of these a
lot of these elements to bring the
credibility to roger's story but i knew
i couldn't fit his story and to beware
of angels because it wouldn't do his
story justice
that's why one documentary became two
and now his prayer ministry is is the
inspiration for this next one that i'm
working on so they're all sort of
continued pieces to the puzzle parts of
his legacy to give you a bigger picture
yeah yeah and these other stories help
to illustrate
this this original deception in the
garden of eden that you will not surely
die right we're still dealing with that
which which which goes back to this
whole concept as long as the devil can
create a caricature and minimize anyone
from thinking this is relevant today at
all
this is just a dusty but most americans
have multiple books of the bible but
they don't read them it's in every hotel
it's you know on every street corner
it's yeah the most bought book most
stolen book yeah and the least red and
the least red yeah but
so this is the launch into the tasting
and seeing that the lord is good i'm in
the middle of working on these stories
and
i was in
grants pass oregon where these murders
happened
where these two sisters picked up a gun
and shot someone else in their bible
study group this is the story that roger
wrote his book beware of angels about
i get to grants pass oregon i didn't
have an interview
no one wanted to talk to me
everyone who had been connected to that
prayer group
you can imagine how
ashamed
someone would feel if they had been
deceived by angels claiming to be from
heaven
because it didn't happen overnight it
took five years five years
from the time they started asking
then it was three months later when one
of them in the group who ended up
getting murdered interestingly five
years later
lynn green
she started seeing angels first and then
other people started getting other gifts
and messages i mentioned in our last
episode
but no one would talk to me when i got
there i had an appointment at the police
department and they spent eight hours
with me
it was amazing but i didn't have an
interview
fortunately our associate producers
got a phone number for a pastor in the
area
who happened to know the green family
and got permission for me to call them
and while i was there i got the phone
number to the green family who are the
victims of this crime that happened in
1988.
they hadn't given an interview they
hadn't talked to anyone about it in
decades
so
i pick up the phone i send up a prayer i
call the family i'm on speakerphone so
there's david green jr whose wife's lynn
was murdered
and the two parents david green senior
and his wife lois were they all in the
study group together
the parents
were connected but not physically
present a lot i say connected because
david green senior had written some
materials that were not
they were not biblical concepts
and that's why it's it's been very
important when i released this film that
that although i mentioned that there's
they were seventh-day adventists in the
film
i also make it clear that what they were
teaching and learning from these angels
led them far away from biblical truth
so david green senior and his wife lois
and david green jr they're all on phone
on speakerphone they heard that this
producer from live streams media was
going to call them didn't know me
i didn't know them
and so
i'm there on the phone
i'm like
so
they said
uh i mean you could cut the tension oh
yeah
sure
and they're i mean it's been 30 plus
years for them
so i pick up the phone and i'm on the
phone with david with the family david
green senior his wife lois and david
green jr whose wife was murdered
and i'm talking to them explaining
that i'm interested in interviews and
david green senior says
what good could this possibly do
you want to pull the band-aids off of
our wounds
after more than 30 years
how could this possibly do any good
and i sent up a prayer a silent prayer
and i said
dave mr green um can i ask you a
question he said sure i said
if you gave an interview
that helped one person in this world
avoid
the kinds of deception that today you
regret
falling for
would it be worth it to you
[Music]
and it was silent
and then
lois the mother said chris can i ask you
a question
i said sure louis what is it
she said
is your mother's name aretha
i said
that's kind of an out of the
curveball question are you googling me
i said why sure why do you ask
and then
suddenly i heard some giggles
and you could feel the tension but
suddenly
you know how you can tell the tension
yeah it just suddenly was just falling
and then i heard them
chuckle and david green senior said to
me then
your mother
was my music teacher
oh wow
years ago wow wow
why interesting
crazy connection yeah and then david
green jr says
yes
i took piano lessons from her too oh my
goodness
and they said
she was the most wonderful teacher we
ever had wow and then suddenly
i was family wow
and you were like thanks mom yeah right
the kindness that your mother showed
back then had no idea what kind of seed
that was gonna plant for the future
the next day
david green senior
came to my hotel room
and gave a private exclusive interview
wow because of my mother wow
you're right
the lord was preparing the lord is not
surprised the bible says he knows the
past the present and the future
and um
i just shook my head when i hung up i
was just like lord
yeah and and to be able to share that
with my mom who's passed away since then
uh
what a thrill to serve our god amen
we never know in this crazy world when
all of these dots are going to connect
and he's going to go hey i got you
wow like it says in jeremiah before you
call i will answer
that's right so i have a question then
have they obviously seen beware of
angels they have
um david green senior by the way david
green jr at the time was not so happy to
give an interview it was his wife that
was murdered
and he was still feeling shame um over
his involvement because he was actually
he was actually involved in meditation
he was having what he believed were
spiritual journeys which is nothing more
than astral projection
flying to the holy city and having
visions and bringing them back to the
group
it was very occultish and he was very
aware i had many long conversations with
him and by the way we still can converse
from time to time
david green senior passed away a year
after he gave that interview wow
and so
it's it's amazing david greene jr has
watched the film sharon halstead's two
sons have seen it um the
the oh and they were both present by the
way at the murder the two boys were 12
and 9. they witnessed
their mother pull the trigger
can you imagine the ptsd for a child wow
that's crazy so
they've all seen it and they've said
it's the most accurate presentation that
they've seen wow and three months after
we released uh beware of angels oprah's
production company oxygen and discovery
discovery
what do they call it it's a
uh
anyway it's part of discovery they came
in with a team that's in fascinating
because that's a blessing in disguise
because if they had come previously the
hype would have been over and the
populist wouldn't have seen what you did
but i'm sure that since they came they
did something on it probably i'm
guessing right since the popular
popularity of it
brought people to your video yeah
i'm also wondering too because they
maybe don't share the same
views
i mean the devil's asleep slippery
little snake here well
you really nailed it scotty because they
wanted me to come give an interview the
oxygen people the ones that were
producing for oxygen or the discovery
group and it's been a couple years now
but one of those two were inviting me to
come give an interview
and they wouldn't let me they wouldn't
let me sign a release on behalf of live
streams media they wanted me to sign a
personal release to them wow and i think
and i had it means that you're liable if
someone sues you and you're releasing
them
and i had no say in what sound bites
they use right
and so i declined the interview sure
because i didn't want to be a
representative for my church right and
end up seeing something that was hashed
up cut up and it wasn't representative
of what the truth was yeah oh man now
obviously they have a reputation
obviously to keep
uh but for me it was this is such a
crucial theological issue about about
life after death in heaven and hell and
the devil the reality of a real devil
yeah and you're right their focus was
more about the murder
and everything that went into the horror
of it all right yeah but where's the
hope yeah where's the focus where's the
pointing to this unseen realm rather
than just
looking at human beings who are still
trying to make sense 30 years later and
they're still confused
it doesn't have to be that way right
that was one of my questions as this
this
green family that had been affected in
such a large way
has there been any healing in their
lives since
this have they
you know started going back to church or
anything like that
it's a good question keith i would say
that david green jr is actually much
better spiritually than he was when i
met him in 2016 when i was in grants
pass working on this
he was not willing to agree
i mean i i saw all the evidence in the
murder evidence and i presented it to
him because he kept denying that he was
doing these things and it's right there
in all these ten boxes of all the things
that this group was doing yeah and he
even called the police this is a
document in the court murder case boxes
just to give you an idea of how far they
had gone off the rails all right these
were seventh-day adventist christians
and
david green and his wife lynn actually
believed they had a 500 year old
uh person living at their house
and he could appear in a physical body
he he he could be an ethereal spirit
and
he would come and go and he was like a
vagabond from the past and
it was very all very strange and he act
the reason why it's in the murder box
murder evidence is because he called the
police department to report it
um after he was shot by the halstead
sisters
and so that this just gives you a sense
of you know once you start taking the
bait and and once you start drifting a
little remember this took five years
right this didn't this didn't start
overnight
so but today he he has he's he's he's
admitted to the things that he did that
contributed to the journey this group
went on
he is going back to church
and and he has watched this movie
several times and he
he agrees that it's accurate it's
awesome to hear that there's some
redemption happening in such a horrific
story and it's also important you know
when you look at something like that
it's easy to look at something that a
few people did
and judge an entire group of people by
that and that's really unfair you know
for any of us to do that you know you
can't point to
any one person and say well they you
know represent their entire denomination
or world view
and and cast everything off because of
that right i was just thinking about you
you said that the guy on the phone said
what good can come out of this and now
it's almost like because he did this
film it was good on him
it brought some good to him right yeah i
mean he he came out uh and did the
interview i went to their home before i
left town and had a
season of prayer with him and with his
wife and uh and david green jr and the
parents passed away within a year after
i was there
and so i just praise the lord you know
god god isn't just using us to reach
masses of people out there the lord is
seeking individuals
and sometimes he calls us personally
to go and minister i just have to i just
have to say though
i hope i never have to get
interviewed by you because
from the last show on this show like
everybody dies within like a year
well keep in mind these people were
pretty elderly so don't worry
if it's 30 years from now and we're both
still alive
[Laughter]
yeah check the lug nuts on your wheels
when you drive home today guys okay so i
promised it was called back to ground
zero and so i want to share my birth
story briefly this is the opening for my
second film when morning breaks and
you'll understand why a guy would do a
film about pregnancy loss
my mother had a miscarriage
what she didn't know
was that she had twins
i was that other twin still inside her
womb
now there was no ultrasound in those
days and she continued to have bleeding
and discomfort
so her doctor used ringed forceps to
remove her ineffective iud
then he used the forceps to reach in
grasp and remove any loose material he
could from her womb
last he gave her five days of the drug
methogen
methogen causes the uterus to expel
remaining birth tissues to minimize
bleeding and risk of infection
but her stomach kept growing
and several doctors didn't believe it
was a normal pregnancy
so mom wanted whatever it was surgically
removed
fortunately for me
her ob doctor urged her to wait
i guess you could say i survived a
miscarriage and an abortion
[Music]
so
you are quite lucky to be here
yeah there's there's a lot of reasons
why i shouldn't have been born wow
an iud at the time was 99.6
uh
effective at
contraceptives
my parents already had three healthy
children they couldn't afford one more
my dad was getting ready to start
medical school
and so the iud was put in she gets
pregnant anyway
then she miscarries my twin she doesn't
know she's still pregnant she goes in at
the time standard medical practice go in
with the forceps and pull out the birth
material wow and at the time i'm six
weeks old probably about that about that
big
nowhere to hide in a three-inch uterus
when you're that big yeah
and
so there's no i just see he's just
pushing like your little forceps you
know just littlefinger
you missed it missed it so there's no
there's no food on the walls of the
uterus when the doctor does that uh and
then the five days of the drug method
now methogen for those of you who don't
know out there
is uh had at the time was used as an
early stage abortion drug
wow and
abortions were not legal at that time
otherwise i wouldn't be here
because these four doctors that came in
after mom took five days of that drug by
the way that drug contracts the uterus
to push out all the birth material to to
minimize the risk of infection and
bleeding because mom was having
continued bleeding wow and so it was it
was all standard medical practice wow
there was no way that i shouldn't have
been pushed out
and then of course you had her stomach
growing and the four specialists who
came to consult on the case and not one
of them believed it was a normal
pregnancy
most of them believed it was some kind
of uh tumor
that was growing uh in her stomach
one person believed it was an ectopic
pregnancy a baby growing outside of the
uterus which wouldn't survive
um which could also be a harm to the
mother and so that's the reason why mom
was trying to have surgery to get
whatever it was removed
so her ob doctor was the only doctor out
of the five
that
suspected or had this
obviously the spirit of god
was like giving him hesitation and he
said let's wait four and a half months
now back then you didn't have ultrasound
it was right before ultrasound came out
you had to wait four and a half months
to hear a heartbeat of a living baby in
the mother's womb
that seems like a crazy decision on your
mom's part because you're right
it seems like there's something wrong
something's not right okay wait four and
a half months i'm thinking right
now yeah what if it is a tumor you know
well that's nightmare city for your
mother for my mother talked about the
nightmares that she had that were just
raging at night for her
especially after
by the way the the retired ob doctor
wrote me a long email a few years ago
and he
he was chief of ob county hospital in
l.a
for his whole career and was responsible
for 300 000 baby deliveries
and i asked him i reached out to him i
was curious if he remembered my case and
he sent me this long email and he said
he he absolutely remembered and he
remembered details my mother had
forgotten wow
and it was so humbling to to read
through his his detailed email he
remembered collapsing in in the ex in
the exam chair beside the table when he
heard my heartbeat for the first time
four and a half months just like he just
collapsed out of shock yeah
and um the rest of the pregnancy another
four and a half months
was the these nightmares so it's not
possible that that baby would have its
fingers and arms and legs and toes
um
because of the pulling because of the
methogen because there was no food on
the walls there were so many reasons why
even if i did make it to the world i
would be legless wow you know and when i
finally came into the world
and mom got the report that it was all
there you guys can see yeah yeah yeah
you know so it's ground zero for me
wow it's it's the flashback to ground
zero how many times do you go through
things in your life
when
you you're questioning your faith right
because you're tired right and you go
through disappointment and brokenness
right i went through divorce several
years ago and uh
it actually became the inspiration for
my first film which which is
which is being re-released soon called
single creek god can take what is broken
in you and make something beautiful wow
what is that from that we just watched
this clip is is part of the opening
sequence to my second film called when
morning breaks okay is this out and this
is yeah this is out on youtube it's out
on
amazon okay and um if we have a few more
minutes i can show you uh the single
creek trailer and then tell you the
angel stories let's do it all right
at first people were always asking me
why aren't you married and they have
stopped asking
it was very very hard because i was
young i had her at 18 and i was
shunned i was thrust into
being a single parent all of a sudden
being a widow
making peace with my second time
singlehood sometimes feels like making
friends with a big alligator out here on
this creek
yeah there's been quite a few um
people that have come into my life and i
think oh maybe this is a good thing and
i say oh wait a minute and she said i'm
praying for a man for you
thank you yes we're singles and we have
special needs and
we're like relationally remedial we know
they're there but i don't think that
it's it's on anybody's priority list
if the church doesn't intentionally
include them
this demographic they're being
[Music]
is no excluded thing as happy ever after
oh listen before i even sat all the way
down he i heard him saying
oh
you you're prettier than a zebra and i
so this this is a very interesting
demographic i mean i'm glad that you're
making a project on this because it is
one that you you don't think about you
know like
yeah there's people that have had these
terrible experiences and and where do
you go from here
it's an awkward topic in in the
christian church at large and it's not
just our denomination but
but everyone that i've talked to and
this is one that goes across
without doctrinal sensitivities right
it's a social issue kind of like
pregnancy loss is a social issue and i
wanted to take the politics off of it
and just let people see because so many
of us when we go through something some
broken disappointment we think that what
we're going through is worse than what
someone else is going through right
and
i've come to see and understand
that
nobody's pain is worse than anyone
else's right and that we're all broken
we're all in need of a savior equally in
need of a savior yeah and so that's what
really what these two films were about
and this is how i got started it's just
that we pulled single creek off the
market for a time and we had to update
it for it's a long story but we're
re-releasing it here soon that's awesome
i'm i'm really glad to
hear a story of you taking something
that's happened in your life and
flipping it around and saying lord how
can i use this experience to bless
somebody else i mean that's that's
awesome it was really cathartic because
my church pastor invited me and this is
this is the back story on this one he
invited me to be the singles ministry uh
administrative pastor at my local church
when i was still in orlando years ago
and at first i'll be honest guys
privately i was offended
i was offended that i had to go around
hey i'm singles ministry you know and in
the film i there's this really fun
segment in the film that we talked about
the awkwardness of singles ministry
programs in churches
it's hilarious actually who in here is
not married yeah
i told my pastor i said let me let me
think about it and pray about it for 30
days and i'll get back with you wow and
during that 30 days i remember reading
everything i could get my hands on what
a singles ministry pastor does and i
remember the day i was looking at the
job description i had downloaded online
and while i was reading it i was just
like
so bored out of my gourd when i was
reading what they do that didn't
resonate with me at all right and and
i've i heard
you know if the lord has spoken to you
in your life you you know
you're thinking about something else and
just like in the bible almost every time
the lord speaks to a human being in the
bible he asks you a question
to get your attention
because you're in the conscious realm
you're thinking you're doing life and i
heard a voice say to that's not you is
it
and out of that
was this concept this idea that we
should do a film to address this this
social issue
this awkwardness and and do something
that could be inspiring not only for
single adults but also church leaders
and married people as well
i've seen married people weep when they
see one of these amazing testimonies in
the film we've reenacted parts of it
and this this blonde girl stacy who is
now married by the way and happily so
with children so god answered her prayer
but she was still single when she did
this interview and she was weeping when
she was describing how she had gone away
for a week in retreat to try and connect
with god and just leave her burdens on
on on the floor and when she came to
this cabin she saw there was this guest
book where all these couples had been
celebrating their
couple-ness
she's like
and she's there alone and anyway god
spoke to her when she was there and it
was the inspiration for the theme song
that i wrote god gave me a song that i
wrote and sang for the film
and uh the lord spoke to her and asked
her am i not enough for you
and she kept pushing the voice she kept
pushing it away she was studying the
bible this voice came back again
and finally she realized the lord was
trying to get her attention
and she started weeping on camera and i
was weeping while i was filming her
because it was so compelling
that the god of heaven knows where you
are he knows your needs and i've seen
married people weep when they hear that
amen to remind them that you're not
complete because you're married that's
right right that's right we've got our
own battles yeah and she's married today
so it wasn't like god was saying you're
gonna be single he sometimes he and this
is in eric wilson's wife's testimony too
like
god told her that they were gonna be
back together but
also god said would you serve me and
love me if eric didn't come back and she
was just like
devastated and we wasn't hearing from
god and she said yes i will and it was
like god was saying finally now i can
work with you he has to know that
he has to reveal to you whether he's
really first in your life or not or is
this marriage on a pedestal and that's
like the only thing you're going after
you know the bible says you are complete
in
him colossians 2 10. that's right and
that's the verse that comes out at that
part of the film to remind all of us
where where where is it in our
brokenness that we go to find whole and
healing it's not our spouse
in the end they can't
fix your brokenness
so i hope that was inspiring for you
guys that's that's a vulnerable place
you know to share your brokenness but
you know if it can help someone else
it's worth it so where do we go to see
all these i mean i know this one's not
out yet right because you are
reproducing it but when that happens
when where do we go our distributor is
going to be releasing it soon um
i've sent them the updated uh version
and so it should be soon if you guys
want to uh subscribe on our youtube
channel we'll be sending out
notifications and updates cool so invite
you guys to come and check out our
youtube channel we've got a lot of roger
morneau stuff there the actual roger
morneau very nice and um and just a lot
of new stuff that we're working on and
that's live streams media
youtube channel is my live streams but
like if you just google live streams
media you can find it we'll put a link
in the description below
do you want to hear about the angels
do we have time
all right so you know what i i think we
we we christians talk a lot about spirit
realm and and things like that and
deceptions and and we learn the
scriptures that help us to defend that
reality and those those are all real
deceptions but there's something as i've
been working in this journey of
unmasking spiritualism this last eight
years guys that the lord has shown me
uh in reality that the devil is
beginning to manifest in physical body
human form
in an increasing
uh increasing level
uh
i had done a tv interview and i was
talking about the screenplay for this
for this story roger mourinho's story
and i was talking about how we were
going to
be looking for a script writer to help
us to partner with and
a couple days after that interview i got
a phone call from a lady who
talked about how she had been a
a writer in hollywood during the late
70s early 80s she was very successful at
the program she had done now she's
retired and she has time and she would
love to help
well do you partner with people before
you find out a little bit about their
worldview
you should
yeah usually
so we chatted for a while and as we were
talking she let me know that she was a
sunday protestant that she went to
church faithfully every sunday and we
were talking
and she said you know my son passed away
15 years ago and i said i'm so sorry she
says oh that's okay
he came to visit me two years ago
i said really
she said oh yes she said he i was in my
master bedroom getting dressed one
morning and he walked right through the
door like he did when he was alive and
came and sat down
on the bed next to me and gave me a big
hug and i said esther can i interrupt
you
she said sure what is it i said can i
ask you a question just to clarify
this was not a spirit that came through
the wall
this was a physical body that came
through the doorway
and sat down she said absolutely you had
to open the door
she said he had his hand on the doorknob
he came in she said he sat down next to
me and these were the these were the
the proofs because remember seeing and
feeling and hearing is becoming the
nature of reality for the world if you
see it you believe it's becoming truth
it's becoming their truth right right
and so she said i felt the breath on my
neck i felt the warmth of his skin
he embraced me and i felt his heartbeat
that's crazy that's scary
yeah how is she just not like she was
describing it in detail
very physical characteristics and then
she said he didn't stay long
and he didn't say much
he got up and he before he went back
through the door
he turned around and he said to me
thanks mom for getting the word out
everything is light love and eternity
on the other side wow
and he turned around and he went back
through the door and she hasn't seen
that manifestation of her son
since then now she's had dreams lucid
dreams where he comes to her he's done
practical jokes through relatives doing
things that only they would know so
again there's your proof
because they're private things that only
your family members would know no
stranger would know
um and so i thought about that you know
for a long time and i thought how is the
devil going to have to deceive the whole
world he's got to somehow
manifest as
a resurrection he's got he's got a
masquerade as jesus actually physically
raising a physical body
and this is the beginning of what i
think we're seeing now you say well how
can you believe that that that really
happened what credence do you give to
her story why do you believe she's
telling the truth because you know some
people are watching today and they're
saying ah she's just an old lady that's
just
uh
imagining things hallucinating because
maybe she's you know taking too much
this or that in her supplements
you know
i say
i've had an experience
at the beginning of the show you said
what would you do if you were confronted
with a with an angel and
you know one day guys i was out running
with a friend years ago i was training
for a marathon
i was in southern virginia i was out in
a field of straight road with barbed
wire fences
and we had been running for 45 minutes
and we were on the last leg we were
getting ready to make one turn and then
head down another mile to where we were
staying out in out in the country
and as we were getting ready to turn
this corner i saw dark clouds in the
distance coming towards us very rapidly
and before we knew it as we tried to run
faster
this storm overtook us it was a it was a
it was a it was a spring storm coming
coming on us
and
and the lightning started to hit and
thunder was crashing
i don't know if you guys have ever been
out during lightning storm and have the
lightning hit
very close to your car while you're
driving not yet
it's it's it's fairly um
blood curdling yeah
we we've tried to outrun the rain was
filling our shoes uh
no matter how fast we could not outrun
it the lightning was hitting closer and
closer and close and when it's when it's
when it hits right beside you it doesn't
there's no echo it's just an explosion
yeah
and as god is my witness a lightning
bolt hit within 10 feet of us oh wow man
right off the road
right on the other side of the barbed
wire fence i remember like it just
happened
and i looked at my friend steve and i
and we turned around there was nowhere
to go straight road barbed wire fences
on both sides open fields no cover
um
i said we're gonna die
make her peace
because we couldn't do anything and
suddenly this car came up
behind us
and
uh we ran and jumped down
we were we were i was sitting you know
it was a woman and i was sitting within
closer to her shoulder just it was a
tiny car
you remember the hugo back in the old
days yeah this was it was something like
that a tiny little shoe box
so she was real close to my shoulder
i introduced to myself myself sorry i
hit the mic
i introduced myself to her and my friend
steve introduced steve to her and i
asked her name and she looked at me and
she said um
mary
you stammered and said that
exactly
this car suddenly shows up in the middle
of a lightning storm that's my first
clue second clue she doesn't know her
name
third clue you know when you you when
you've been exercising and you're really
sweaty and hot and you jump in a cool
car what happens to the windows yeah
but you're not just sweaty you're
drenched in water yeah yeah
yeah every but we were still very hot
because we had been running for over an
hour
uh training and so our bodies instantly
fogged up the windows and there mary
goes and starts driving but you can't
see out the window
that's clue number two
i'm thinking this is strange especially
when the next thing happens i said can
we turn on the defroster i can show you
where where to take us because she was
going to take us and drop us off
and
she doesn't know how mary doesn't know
how to operate her
defroster wait wait it just occurred to
me she's continuing down the road and
she doesn't even know where to go yet
yeah so we just said go straight we're
staying okay you know about a mile from
here and remember it's just it's out in
the country with no
corners no
houses it's just fields and it's a
straight road wow and so she starts
driving but again you can't see out the
window and she doesn't know how to
operate i just find out she doesn't know
how to operate her defroster
so i'm fumbling around on the dash
you've done that before and eventually
you figure it out and so eventually we
pull up she turns over beside the road
there's an opening in the fence
we jump out it's still raining
i run
10 feet
and i was just like i had to see i had
to see
i
turned around and ran right back to the
road it was only a couple of seconds
i look to my left straight road no hills
i look to my right
no car
it's gone wow
no
no well
wow
that was a physical car
that was a
physical person
it was a small car that's why i like to
sometimes say it's it was the angel in
the hugo yeah
because it's not like it was a huge you
know
that was it was a physical experience
and the bible says in hebrews 13 chapter
2 be
don't forget to entertain strangers
for therein some are entertaining angels
unawares
so there we see that god sometimes
allows his angels to manifest in human
form we see it in the book of genesis
several times
and other places in the old testament
where angels come in human form right
well
it happened to me
this biblical context again everything
that happens to us
we filter through this that's right
that's right
and we pray for discernment from the
holy spirit it feels like there's an
attack on your life and a protection on
your life man you should have been not
even born
tree fell on your house bearing your
yard lightning striking right next to
you angels protecting you like this is
amazing yeah mm-hmm
i'm sure there's more oh well there's
stuff that we didn't have time to cover
today guys
you'll have me back
we'd love to have you back
have you ever thought about making a
movie about just your life i
i have i promised my parents before they
died that i would write a book someday
and that may be
uh like a conduit through which to
possibly do a film yeah yeah i'd love to
see it make it the seventh film yeah
it'll be perfect
i actually have a domain
you covered me nice this comes from this
comes from psalm 139 very nice i
couldn't believe the domain was
available guys because it's my favorite
go to remember go back to ground zero
find out where god was faithful to you
and remember amen hold on to that amen
psalm 139 says you covered me in my
mother's womb
wow
and there in a couple verses it says
that he scheduled every day of your life
before there was one of them
he wrote it in a book
so god knew you personally before you
were even in your mother's womb this is
the message this is the hope and it's
far greater far more you know we spend
so much time to unmask spiritualism and
it's been such a we talked about that
scotty yesterday yeah last episode and
and the burden is heavy for us and
that's why it's such a blessing to share
with you guys especially here in this
set in the studio with little light
studios god's given you a message
but we have a heaviness sometimes and
we've got to go back to ground zero
absolutely and find where god was strong
for us
that's what i believe amen amen wow an
appropriate place to end on a show
called light exposing darkness um light
is more powerful than the darkness and
so thank you so much for blessing us
charmed by darkness you guys if you
haven't checked out his film please
click on the link below watch his film
amazing amazing production get this book
the story of roger morneau beautiful
beautiful story and uh chris thank you
so much we'll have you back again i'm
sure and
thank you for coming thank you guys for
watching and uh we hope that you were
blessed by today's show um thank you
guys so much for donating to our
ministry like this video share it with
someone that you would you you think
would be blessed by this material as
well and uh for those of you that have
prayed for our ministry donated on
patreon we want to thank you because
this would not be possible without you
guys absolutely thank you so much and
we'll see you next week
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
you